here is a simple boilerplate contract  for my services  that one goes here  of course  what the collection of a compressionists  you have here pre post  Neo all the best prefixes I was robbed a  few years ago so I don't keep anything  of value in the building those are  reproductions that's how we introduce my  children  what do you sail I do not uh I have an  aversion of boat shoes well shoes in  general but boat shoes in particular I  mean is it a slipper or is it a shoe  come on  is this a model of your boat well yes  I'm embarrassed to admit that is  well she's beautiful thank you I hope to  see you soon Mr indeed  [Music]  always fondling my boat